le gouvernement a prévu de dévoiler mi
novembre ses propositions en matière de
bien-être animal
la mairie de paris prend les devants en
organisant une délibération qui sera
soumis au vote au conseil de paris et 12
et 14 novembre et qui vise à interdire
la tenue de spectacles avec des animaux
sauvages
selon les spécialistes les besoins des
animaux sauvages ne peuvent pas être
respecté en captivité prenons par
exemple les besoins physiologiques comme
l'alimentation
un éléphant parcourent des kilomètres
par jour pour chercher sa nourriture à
lyon va chasser quand il a faim il part
en groupe il va chasser il mange il est
rompu pendant deux trois jours il mange
plus en captivité ces animaux on le
rapporte à heures fixes l'alimentation
non pas leïla chercher la nourriture
n'est pas du tout équilibrées pour eux
ça correspond pas aux besoins
nutritionnels confirmant aux animaux
domestiques comme les chats et les
chiens les animaux sauvages ne sont pas
faits pour être apprivoisé ni dressé
lors les méthodes de dressage sont
effectivement des méthodes coercitives
pour obtenir que le lion va
effectivement ils passent dans un
cerceau de feu qui monte sur un tabouret
c'est pas du tout ce qui se passe dans
la nature bon que des éléphants
effectivement face le bo face les pieds
au mur et ce qu'on voit des éléphants
qui doivent se tenir sur leurs troncs et
sur leurs pattes avant et lever le train
postérieur c'est contre les postures
normal donc des animaux dans les cirques
les animaux captifs montre des signes de
souffrance le principal troubles du
comportement qu'on peut observer dans
les dom les animaux captifs dans les
cirques
c'est ce qu'on appelle les stéréotypes y
alors les stéréotypes et c'est le
terreau mythologique ce le terme médical
et troubles compulsifs c'est-à-dire un
animal va répéter le même comportement
sans signal d'arrêt donc c'est le cas
par exemple dans un dans une cage vous
voyez le lion qui va de l'eau en large
de long en large tout le temps
l'éléphant qui se balancent d'une patte
sur l'os qui bat qui balance la tête ça
sont des stéréotypes et franchement
soins le comportement le plus clair pour
exprimer la souffrance animale
l'espérance de vie de ces animaux est
également réduite elle est déjà diminué
à
lloris dans les eaux a fortiori dans les
cirques parce que les animaux qui sont
stressés toute la journée ils sécrètent
du cortisol ou cortisol une hormone de
stress qui va entraîner une immuno
suppression des doors et des animaux
immunodéprimées donc ils sont plus
réceptifs aux maladies opportunistes ils
seront exposés aussi a des gros
problèmes cardiaques
ils seront prédisposés à des maladies
aussi gastro entérite hic ils seront
prédisposés à des maladies musculaires
et osseuses
parce qu'on leur fait faire comme les
éléphants des mouvements qui sont contre
nature alors que faire de ces animaux
faut-il les réinsérer dans leur milieu
naturel et sont inaptes à se réhabituer
aux mulets naturel pourquoi parce que ce
sont des jeunes qui n'ont pas déjà
appris surtout dans les eaux les codes
de communication
donc ils connaissent pas n'ont pas
appris les rituels ni ne connaissent pas
du tout comment fonctionne puisque le ya
pas de bébé en trop avec les adultes
donc ça comment ça fonctionne et savent
pas chassés ils ne savent pas
communiquer avec les autres espèces
parce que pour eux dans un cirque
ils sont avec des éléphants on voit des
lions des tilles puisque par parfois on
voit dans une même cage qui est
complètement aberrant une espèce sociale
par exemple qui est un lion qui doit
vivre en groupe
avec une espèce solitaire qui est le tir
dont on fait cohabiter des tigres et des
lions qui sont deux espèces complètement
différente n'ont pas appris ce que
c'était qu'un prédateur pour eux et
l'autre par comme ils sont quand même
habitué à l'homme hip hop être à
l'origine d'accidents sont leur mue en
liberté ces animaux ne peuvent donc pas
revenir à leur milieu naturel
si les animaux sauvages sont interdits
dans les cirques ils pourront être
placés dans des réserves naturelles avec
des espaces suffisant et nécessaire à
leur bien-être